so in what appears to be one of the
worst cases of migrant deaths in the
united states in recent years at least
46 people have been found dead inside a
track in texas the discovery was made on
the outskirts of san antonio 16 people
found alive are being treated in
hospital
patients that we saw were hot to the
touch
they were suffering
from heat stroke heat exhaustion
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer but there
was no visible working ac unit on that
rig
let's cross straight away to rosalyn
jordan he joins us live from washington
dc ross what more do we know at this
point
well the situation started unfolding
about four hours ago and that's when a
worker at a facility in a nearby
industrial yard
heard someone screaming went out and uh
called
up at this 911 which was parked on a
road outside this industrial yard and
discovered the 46 dead people as well as
the other 16 people who were then taken
to nearby hospitals for heat exhaustion
and in some cases heat stroke and which
means those people were very close to
perhaps dying
it was a very hot day in san antonio
which is in southern texas
temperatures in the
upper 20s uh some suggesting perhaps in
the low 30s and inside a truck without
air conditioning the temperatures were
even higher now authorities did say they
have arrested
or detained i should say three people
but it's not clear whether they are
connected to the situation with this
tractor trailer being found on the side
of the road authorities did spend some
time on monday evening looking through
some nearby woods to see if there were
any other people who might have been
connected to this truck either as
passengers or perhaps involved with the
movement of the truck but so far they
haven't found anything now this is an
investigation even though local police
and fire departments
responded it's now being conducted by
the department of homeland security
which does suggest that this could be
and i stress could be a human
trafficking case
all right ross leave there for the
moment thanks very much uh let's speak
to john holman who joins us from mexico
city john what reaction are you hearing
from there
well the mexican foreign minister has
been really active actually mostly on on
twitter
giving out information about this some
of it has already gone out in the u.s
press the fact that 16 people have been
taken to hospital he said that in the
group of those 16 people taken to
hospital two people from guatemala have
been identified and four miners um he
also says uh interestingly especially
what roz after what ross just said that
the trailer actually had uh plates uh
that would put on u.s plates on top of
other plates sort of suggesting that
they're fake plates and he said after
that um it's very probable that this was
done by people smugglers so
that sort of information that's coming
from mexican foreign ministry
this is something in terms of people via
people smuggling groups being taken up
this route from central america or even
further south through mexico into the
united states that happens quite
regularly we've actually followed and
tracked a convoy of those of those
trucks heading north through the state
of chiapas in the very south of mexico
in the past and another time we followed
people going all the way up to the u.s
border and it has resulted in tragedies
before it was only in december of last
year 2021
when even more people
more than 50 people died in the back of
the trailer in that southern state of
chapus when they were involved in a road
accident so this is something obviously
that people are doing because they're
desperate they want to get to the united
states they want to avoid the
checkpoints that especially in the south
of mexico uh there's there's there's
different checkpoints trying to stop
people get through uh the
larger criminal groups in mexico some of
them are involved in the trafficking of
people to get them up that route uh to
the united states and people can pay
thousands of dollars
to get up to that route but obviously
the conditions in which they're being
transported uh are far far from ideal as
the tragedy of tonight's uh where there
was a lack of air conditioning obviously
and people suffer from heat stroke in
that truck indicate
all right john thanks very much indeed
and bringing more on this story as we
get it